hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots hi I don't know what happened
last anything happened interesting I
don't know what happened I'm hung over
yeah so why you hung over yeah what
happened why you hung over I don't know
we had a little fun last night so fun I
did a little celebrate did a little
Victory lap last night a little liquid a
little liquid Victory lap so um yeah
so
yesterday
um
MCH was invited to by the way
100% by by Alex's producer Alex had idea
Jimmy my boy Jimmy what up dog yeah so
Jimmy and merch
decided what decided to just like be
real mean like for no reason you know
uh you decided to ask Dom ler some
questions I know Dom ler is he's the
breaker of of um narratives narratives
The Watermark
kid The Watermark kid yeah the watermark
kid for those of you that don't know who
Dom ler is he's that guy on Twitter who
has that one dreadlock at the front of
his head that's just holding on for
[__] dear life yeah doing the best
that it can yeah
so look we'll
just everybody's so big this one people
are so mad people even think I'm the
[__] the biggest hero in the world or
the biggest piece of [__] today I'm
seeing a lot more Heroes than piece of
[__] to be honest with you but uh here
this is this is Let's Play a clip here
from Alex Stein's uh show which you can
catch on the blaze mhm listen all I want
to know is first of all I'm really
freaked out why is his watermark on my
screen Dom are you in my computer right
now shut
up h m get out of my computer get off
get out of here Dom get out of here
don't Watermark my show come on
listen producers in the back is howling
no I'm mad that Dom calls himself a
Creator what do you create
Dom stat and the other 50% is just [__]
you stole from other people in waterm I
create I'm a Creator I create waves oh
he creat you don't swim no sir I I
believe I believe what you meant to say
was watermarks you create watermarks how
do you make waves when you [__]
refuse to get your hair
wet bro I I heard that [__] I create
waves yeah I was [__] crying laughing
dude he spent he spent that entire four
minutes just doing the last scene in
Training Day and then he went on a
Twitter space and doubled down and was
literally doing King Kong ain't got [__]
on me for an hour while people were just
like literally the end of Training Day
just going I'm out of here man everybody
was just walking away from him it was
really fun so hold on let's pill it pill
more for them why not we might as well
you steal is what you do I started a
bait and switch I've did the threads I
had the most viral threats what do I
create I create wavs what do you create
yeah what do you create you create W
with other people
[__] me you $10,000 from people and buy
a $4,000 Gucci jacket and get a meth and
then you went to New York and you just
took the
Jew I mean that's what he did it's what
he did did you see the clip of his
documentary that Alex played yes yes
where he basically just went and they
were like yeah come on in have some
lotas and he's like wow you guys are
great and he just went home so we're
going to go back and forth from this
clip because I wented to splice himself
he literally went like hey what are
those tunnels and they went ah you know
these uh these zumas they they built the
tunnels so they could uh worship in the
tunnels and he went oh cool story well I
got to get back it's good chat he just
gave up
riting we could have sent pessy in there
for [__] two grand and pessy would
have [__] pessy would have been like
I don't believe you no I would have said
p with two grand an iPhone and a lapel
mic that's what I mean he would have
been like you're Fu given and I would
have given them one grand to get actual
answers well $999 pessy pocketed a
dollar for a dollar slice a dollar slice
you got to get a dollar slice while
you're in that my tummy was rumbling I
had to got a little dollar I gave him
$998 I got a I got a can of Coke and a
dollar slice okay let's let's head on
merch I think you should read this
because you didn't even know about this
because this is from today go ahead what
does that say uh Ali London uh tweeted
out I guess Twitter influencer Dom lucer
has been exposed for his sham
documentary after using a years old
interview of a child protection act AC
to attempt to pass it off as new footage
filmed for his the tunnels video Manny
wax an activist Against Child
exploitation slammed lcer for using an
old Zoom interview he did for a TV
channel with Luker attempting to make it
appear as if he was interviewing him as
he appeared watching wat screen and
nodding as he spoke he prep bured him he
prep burgered him with the interview
that the radio people do so he inserted
himself and went uh-huh yeah like like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah here
you want to see here so no you're right
it's before you play Just you're right
it's the prep Burger thing with like hey
we got Taylor Swift in studio she's
telling us all about our new hot album
today Hey Taylor so tell me what
inspired you with this new album oh God
and then there's a music it's there's
always a pause and then a music bet and
you know well I was uh when I was there
they never sound they never sound like
they in the same
place here here you go so I was uh born
and raised uh with in an ultra Orthodox
environment um my dad Australian my mom
israelian
um and I am one of 17 children
n1,000 to film himself watching another
nigga's documentary bro bro what are you
fair and balanced oh he had the nerve to
do this no cuz he actually released his
documentary he didn't even make it so
that it focused on the guy being
interviewed the camera's focused on his
[__] he didn't I trod the religion he
should have thrown in some word word y
like talking to the screen yeah yeah
all encompassing every aspect of your
day is really dictated by religion I I
love that the tide is turning on this
[__] [__] Even in our chat right
now even in our chat right now people
are like oh man I like him I don't know
who did this [__] like right now people
are noticing what was what this guy is
he's just a Content Thief somebody said
he just steals things from forchan can I
read this I'm sorry Super Chat for
brother Cheerio for five I'm thankful to
Megan Kelly for exposing Don Lu Griff
come on man
no God damn it she did it again she got
us again watch next week it's going to
be Tom lucra outed at Megan Kelly for
ambushing him on Alex Stein show I guess
we're both viral loads
now could somebody Photoshop Megan
Kelly's face on Me on the Alex Stein
show please that'd be great thank
you compassing in in terms of the effect
it has on you the expectation on you at
the age of about 11 or 12 years old MH
interesting stuff I was within um a an
institution called the so he filmed
himself in a room
going and by the way by the way like
forget about the grift forget about
stealing from people yeah wouldn't you
just feel weird filming that yes like
just a it's like someone filming you
while you're watching Smackdown like why
why are you filming my face bunch of
podcast like that on YouTube where it's
literally their face while they watch
[__] no thanks Mexicans cuz that's
who smackdown's for uh it is no and now
Mexicans and Maven for some reason hey
Maven can you go away please we we
didn't want you when you were around 20
years ago we don't want you now tell
nice drop kick [__] Ultra Orthodox um
main institution of our community Ultra
Orthodox community in mb Australia and
um we used to um study from early in the
morning till late at night and um people
from the community his role besides from
working can we start doing these like as
a joke on our show like where we play a
video and we pretend we're interviewing
the guy that would be great we just go
really interesting regular job uh he but
it has to be like JFK like somebody
who's dead at black and white so it
looks we being a oh wow by the way did
you film this in the Jew
tunnel filed it in a kitchen he turned
all the lights off and had a [__] one
of the camera lights yeah that no that
light is from the hood over his stove
they're doing the thing come on man this
is like uh lucer raised over $10,000
from his Twitter followers to film this
documentary titled the tunnels in which
he claimed would have exposed a secret
child traffing operation in the recently
uncovered tunnels under a Jewish
synagogue in New
York
uh and and by the way you know what you
did you idiot any any like legitimate
any like legitimate like you know
question pal brick suit I've never had a
bad word list all I want to know is
first of all I'm check check Frozen's
flurry real quick never had a bad word
to say about brick suit I always liked
that guy you were the one that was
always talking [__] about we did like we
did like 30 minute bits like five years
ago about what a nerd he was you did I
was you were like the okay that's my
buddy you know what MCH yeah you're
right hey hey brick suit I'm so
sorry I think your
suit's pretty cool man here you go Mar
you [__] happy with
yourself wow that is not a flattering
Megan Kelly picture either Jesus Christ
can you show me a flattering Megan Kelly
picture yeah she looks good she looks
good on TV when Kelly under very
controlled that was a picture of Megan
Kelly like on her way to Kroger in the
middle of the day K that's natural
sunlight Megan Kelly Megan Kelly might
have stolen my [__] and all that stuff
but like she can still get it like I'm
not going to sit here and pretend me
Star Girl Starlight could still [__]
get
stolen
from it's just that if I was [__]
Starlight I'd be picturing what she used
to look like you know it's kind of like
[__] like running into an
ex-girlfriend for 15 years ago and
[__] them and you're like I'm going
to up here you're 15 years ago yeah like
every dude who's married
um exposing it's on my Instagram live
right now
yeah but but you were a lifelong
conservative d
M what are you trying Instagram right
now all right so wait wait wait wait can
I
ask I am I was
a designer I had requests to make I was
a design that was a design dumb yeah he
designed it dog I liked it when I said
like was to bringing up conservatism
he's like I used to work for bankroll
fresh and I'm like oh it's very
conservative of
you and then like Alex is like who's
bank roll fresh I'm like he's a dead
rapper who Comm a bunch of
[Laughter]
felonies shirts I made them by demand if
they make no question I'm not now I'm
mad because I should have thought of it
but what I should have said was every
black guy I know makes shirts like
what's your point yeah no seriously you
show me I could throw listen you put me
in a room full of black guys and I throw
a rock randomly I'm going to hit a guy
who sells t-shirts let me guess you also
have a SoundCloud like no really you
sure no way no [__]
way shs and then you and now they don't
even sell CDs MCH they don't give you
CDs on the side they have [__] QR
codes if you seen that you give $5 you
have this can of QR code you didn't get
physical even the grifters don't give
you physical media anymore now you go to
[__] Time Square to like give me $5
scan this QR code you're like what it's
like all this is free on Soundcloud
anyway and it
sucks by the way by the way with those
colors on doesn't doesn't Dom look like
an injured like cornerback from
Washington the quadria Smith Oklahoma
yeah man I mean it was like game two
when I was out for the whole
season sold the he looks like a football
player that has IR next to his name yeah
this does look like a screenshot from
like a weird Sports
[Laughter]
show or a wrestling podcast we can
easily be talking about how bad aw is in
this it is it's true it's true very good
he looks like a black wrestling fan he
looks like the guy that would be
defending aw mhm yeah yeah yeah exactly
he's black gen usually when I commission
somebody look through my comments look
at the rappers I was engaging with
bankroll fresh designer look at the
people I was engaging look at the people
that was
talking do that is dop that is dope mer
[__] Alex piece of [__] Alex you
piece of [__] he is a [__]
[__] he rules what a piece of
starving autist is now just naming
people from the kmv sketch lar Patron
Duke
Mar
I love the one it's like University of
Mississippi in Ohio in Miami no my
favorite is my favorite is
fudge
fudge mine is mine is the one where he
has the he has the grills I don't know
why it makes me laugh it goes [__] [__]
oh yeah good yeah I know that one he's I
always say that one out loud when I'm
like like I'm in a goofy mood because
it's the one where he goes University of
South Florida penguin in the chos
penguin in the CH goes Hingle
mccringleberry
God damn it
name conserv were you conservative when
you roll used to I don't care what you
used to no
no let me say this m let's be real I I
like you m we're friends obviously but
but but you're not perfect either your
pass isn't perfect mine's not I'm far
from perfect call myself a Visionary how
many who are you merch who you is I
waves yeah I make waves whenever I jump
in a pool and I'm
drunk I
don't what are you doing for the
community he did what are you doing for
the community what are you doing for the
movement what are you doing for the lot
more than you are D and I'm making a lot
less money for it too jag off you know
why cuz people like you keep stealing
our
[__] all right people like you keep
stealing our [__]
[__] Tom morell's Mercedes for dollar
said boys you have more viewers than Kim
Iverson and she's got titties oh I have
titties have you seen them has anyone
seen Kim Harv's titties if they're
publicly out there could somebody do me
a favor get a picture of uh Kim
Iverson's tits put it Don Luker
watermark over him
please over each of her
nipples he gets busted for revenge porn
because of our stupid joke because of
our stupid [__] joke uh Kim Aon you
have been chosen to be exposed
literally excuse your tits
oh
[__] this guy's got an alling eye
around buying Gucci Co look at that
putting your Twitter b boom how many
followers you get now 600 I got like 700
700 new followers on his
count can I just shout out to uh shout
out to JV for also putting the right
Twitter handle thank you thank you yes I
didn't even give it to him so thank you
for that yeah I I got to say this too
it's so funny that like that the ghost
of MCH Twitter account is like a month
old and it already has more like 10
times more followers than all the fake
merch account one month it immediately
blew
up uh so by the Gordon flower shirt I
just just realized you're wearing Gordon
flower shirt money what have you done
what have you done for the movement
merch what have you done for the
movement I I'm not a part of any
movement I hope the whole country Burns
to the [__] ground that's still a
movement it's acceleration movement but
it's a movement that's fair enough and
you've done a lot for that movement so
that's good I have you for the
go how's Lauren witzky doing is she
still doing
meth he was not happy about that
either a Chicago your producer still
doing
meth you're a piece of [__] you're a
piece of [__] he was not ready for that
huh went down to the Jewish Shad someone
went down the day after the Chicago
Rapper went the day after and he went
viral what are you influencing he went
viral but about money and viral and
numbers to this guy 100% and that's
exactly what I was about to say too it's
like just notice what drives this guy
what drives this guy is not the truth
you know no what drives this guy is what
drives every black guy I've ever met in
my life I want to go viral I want to be
viral all that's all you give a [__]
about huh yeah Dom it's almost as if
black guys have shitty priorities
they do I'm sorry I'm not apologizing
for
that is that all you [__] care
about what are you actually doing what's
your real life change how many black
Americans have you convinced to vote red
the world would be the exact same I've
been flipping as many blue as I
physically possibly can as a matter of
fact I like that even just me going hey
Dom was just getting under his skin so
much he was so angry he did a [__] he
did like an hour and a half Twitter
space where he just [__] cried and
and smeared [__] all over the walls and
had a tantrum when when his only when
his only retort back is yeah how many
followers do you have you're like what
the [__] does that even matter Bud
here's the thing Dom I've actually get
been nuked more times on social media
than [__] you could even count mhm so
so that's more than four and by the way
every time I've been nuked it's by
creating yeah that's okay you're an
[__] Roy that deserved more than it
got thank you thank
you oh no he can count to 10,000 this
[__] guy or
$3,995 cuz that's the MSRP on that Gucci
jacket by the way I I don't know if
there's a tape that exists now except
when we were watching it live on
nightwave but he did an hour and a half
Twitter space doing basically the end of
like Training Day King Kong and got [__]
on me screaming in his little hug box
with all his followers and the funniest
part of that Twitter space was like an
hour and this guy waited patiently for
an hour and they were like CH yeah let's
let's uh let's add this guy blah blah
blah he's like yeah hey Tom I want to
ask about the tunnel chirp and it was
really [__] loud and they immediately
hung up on him and I was bro I thought I
was gonna [__] have a stroke last
night I thought I was gonna die I was
laughing so [__] hard at
that God damn whoever waited an hour
just to play a [__] chirp is the
funniest person in that space I saw that
I actually saw I was [__] dying and
it hit me CU we were watching it live so
it just hit me out of the blue and I was
like holy
[__] oh they were so mad you died today
bro if you never were born [__] would
never change out
here if you never were if you never were
born [__] would never change out here
that's not true sir without me uh you
know I don't know I got nothing that
chick wouldn't had to get an abortion
that one time yeah exactly AB one
abortion huh all the cats would be
uncared for in Lakeland and there'd be a
lot less girls with itchy
crotches again more than
four you should never you should never
give a man a hypothetical about if he
was never born because MCH could have
easily fired back to him about whether
or not he had breakfast yesterday yeah
it is
true you should have just been like but
I was born yeah but I was born
though that would have been the funnyest
[__] ever but I was
Bor I have near helped you know what D
and Twitter would be a lot better place
if you weren't born and your great aunt
didn't raise you oh come on
man I've helped change what
accepted literally changed the [__]
the repblic you're full of hubus is
great that was good you're full of hum I
just at this point I knew he was gonna
hang up I was like let him
spiral listen to this guy it's it's all
you is the reason you have a popular
Twitter account [__] yeah anyone
would be pissed if they come on someone
show when you're
done I'm on your side I'm on your let's
calm down let's calm down calm down Cal
like I'm crazy for being pissed by the
way this was I was proud of this one
where I just was like fine I'll behave
don't worry don't worry Alex I'll
behave it's just one of those he still
screaming Alex is going everybody calm
down I got you buddy I'll behave he got
angry he's what a mighty white decision
of you very very low impulse control
here because this is this is almost like
when you're like if you were boxing in a
ring right and it's like he's trying to
like sneak shots after the bell rings
I'm not going to fight back like you're
the one losing points right now I'm just
going to all right fine hit me it's fine
the reason my producer Jimmy everybody
chill everybody chill he left and he's
gone a hop did he leave a gosh dang it
gosh dang it Alex you [__] assho Alex
is such a DI Alex rules thanks Jimmy
you're the man um so msh I think you'll
appreciate
this um I had Gavin g g Gavin mcginness
commissioned something from pessy from
pessie is that we have to go through
Gavin now Gavin yes unfortunately that's
just how it is it is it is black it is
black we wanted to surprise you we
worked on it today pessy put this
together through Gavin mcginness oh it
is the first day of this month yeah so
uh M I was thinking of making a new one
of these too I just can't think of any
black people I care to think Geor Floyd
here you go that's a good one yeah here
you go MCH this one was just for you
Taylor Just For You February is Black
History Month where we celebrate
African-Americans who have helped make
our nation the global Beacon of strength
and Liberty it is through their
significant culture
economic or political contributions each
week we here at revenge of the Cy will
highlight one of these heroes in our
Black History Month Spotlight segment
this week we honor Dom lucr breaker of
narratives with humble beginnings as a
clothing vendor soon realized his
passion for justice in the American way
was too
strong he soon climbed the ranks on
Twitter as a trusted investigative
journalist by accusing multiple
celebrities of being pedophiles
Don LCRA broke The Narrative of needing
proof to back up your accusations giving
into the old adage fake it till you make
it whether he's sacrificing his social
media accounts to fight exploitation or
protecting smaller content creators by
sh strong namea Lisa one thing's for
sure what a dick Dom lucr is one genuine
guy we here at our OTC thank you for
your
service that's awesome thank you pessy
oh
you're we figured you would enjoy that
oh [__]
dude by the way I do like the fact that
you showed that tweet I never realized
before too how he like the Jim Carrey
thing was one I I like I went at him
about too I was like you should call
random people pedopiles like but like I
love the fact that like cuz we all
remember that stupid Emma Stone video
and it was like awkward and weird but
like the fact that he even said he said
he wanted to take it to the prom and
have sex with W and I'm like that was
never in that video that was in that
video I think we would have all
remembered that part yeah no and look
I'm not defending Jim Carrey I think
he's a [__] weirdo right but that
being said that was not anything well no
that was Dom while watching the video
thinking wow I would take Emma Stone to
the prom SE witha yeah exactly yeah but
unfortunately Dom in order to take Emma
Stone of the prom you got to make it to
your [__] senior year of high
school is that more is that more than
four that's way more than okay I know
okay well that's probably why he doesn't
know uh let the best seven years of his
life oh [__] I became a doctor in high
school um brother Cheerio I'm thankful
to Megan Kelly for exposing Dom Lucas
grift piece of [__] uh 200 watt in the
chat said where's Ethan I think he means
Ethan man skyver he's banned from the
show he'll be on second hour he's
absolutely banned I I found out he was
on today and I said absolutely not on my
[__] watch [__] that guy Ethan will
be on the neth 5:00 hour yeah 5:00 hour
Ethan 5:30 actually but that's that's
when he'll be on oh yeah he just comes
and goes as he he on Dom lcer time yeah
oh that's definitely more than four
North Florida man every time M gets an e
grifter in his crosshairs I start
whistling Farmer in the de listen to be
fair though that was a that was a group
effort uh no yeah we helped out but I
mean you know you you you you killed him
so I did nothing Jack the trigger we
just gave you the gun Jack cat says a
first time long time here talk about
laugh out loud funny uh where do you
guys get your
ideas [__] hey you ever heard of this
live action Flintstones movie how about
Owen Benjamin Frasier was a British
Niles Ted beat in the chat said what
does EVS create
exactly waves I'll make
waves we're going to have Ean on second
hour it's going to be fun
Gat up above hey guys first time
donating enjoy the long weekend and for
the love of God Royce please wash
yourself after that gay Cho wedding
don't want I didn't I'm not going to a
gate people think I'm actually going to
go now they've extended with meren and
think I'm officiating a gate chono
wedding this weekend oh that's nice of
you I'm not doing that you're not even
charging them or anything no I'm
charging them and I you know I couldn't
do the online test fast enough you know
that you just marry anybody have you
seen those um I mean I'm assuming if
you're doing a gay ch wedding then it's
going to be at like one of those really
cheap event venues oh yeah where they
have the kenas the other days where they
have the tables from the Tim Robinson
sketch the white folding tables all the
music is out of two baringer speakers in
the corner you know what I'm exactly
what I'm talking about I've been to poor
people weddings oh my God they're so bad
bro when I grew up in Mastic Beach right
like mastic is a [__] hole and like any
like the the indicator that you quote
unquote made it after high school was
the people that got married and they had
their wedding in Center mariches which
is like the next town over on the way to
the Hampton and it's still very far out
of the Hampton it's still very much but
yeah that was always the oh I'm having a
bougie wedding I'm going to be having
mine in center mariches and it was still
a poor people wedding it was always a
poor people wedding [__] show up and
they don't have stands for the speakers
yeah you just have barrels with ice and
[__] canned sodas in
it I oh God oh my God
7 hey and it's not named brand soda it's
very important no of course it's never
named it's it's not but it's not no it's
it is name brand but it's not Coke it's
Pepsi products it's Pepsi products and
they're like don't worry it's an open
bar but it's just a folding table with
liquor on it there's no barend oh you're
giving me [__] no I live you know my
you know close but instead of cans of
coke they would just have a bunch of 2
lers of public soda for mixers oh I oh
God oh God having nightmares dude I went
to one of those weddings one time and
they had a bottle of [__] Irish
whiskey on the table like that a bunch
of stuff and I just grabbed the bottle
that's perfect just walked around the
wedding with the
bottle he said it was an open bar I
thought this was for everyone yeah what
nobody here drinks [__] Irish
whiskey uh let's see we got more
donations here uh the dude 90 mad here
collecting cats and scalps taking these
clowns down a peg the tener uh this
tenor is for you awesome job dude I
think 4 minutes is a record it's it was
fast he he was gone quick I was so mad
because I still had like [__] I had
at least like seven or eight lines of
notes left and I was like a and then I
was so happy that Alex let me stay on
because then I got to bang those out
while he was gone not only I was like
well I'm still G to get my [__] talk
first off please watch please watch the
entire the entire episode it's on
YouTube so check out the whole thing I
was so mad I didn't get to drop the
Green Dot card ly to his face oh you
know I I have that if you want to see it
though I I did I I was actually proud of
that one I did have that that [__] had
me [__] rolling oh God did somebody
clip it like it was a bad racist
thing that's amazing hey Dom Luca this
is [__] up yall want to see it just
stolen from other people the other half
is why dude when he tweeted out he's
like why am I getting demonetized
meanwhile a month ago he's like Jim car
is 100% definitely a pedophile and then
he had like no proof like you know what
I mean maybe Elon wants to be in The
Mask 3 you don't know um but I will just
I want to clarify he was complaining
that he gets his money 2 hours later
than all the other creators on Twitter
all the other creators on Twitter don't
have a Green Dot card so that might have
been probably look at Alex processing it
I've seen it took him a second I've seen
this clip a few times I actually I was
mad because when I dropped that line at
first I went [__] that bombed I I
thought it bombed and then Alex kind of
picked up on it you see he picked it a
keep in mind look at his face they did
take a Bunch they did take a bunch of
Edibles before the show too they were
fued up Twitter don't have a Green Dot
card so that might have been probably
why that that's racist merch you're such
a piece of
[__] you could see the gears
turn I just love I loved him calling you
a piece of [__] and then immediately
stuffing a cracker in his [__] mouth
dude he was literally eating Cheetos
during the segment before he was
interviewing somebody he was just eating
a little bag of Cheetos oh [__] oh [__]
they were definitely high as a kite it
was so funny too cuz before I went on
last night I actually asked them I'm
like I'm like yo so like what are the
rules what are the rules I was like I
was like what can I when your guest is
black but he's a hack but I was like
listen and I wasn't like I just wanted
to know I said look I'm not going to
come in like machine gunning and bombs
or anything but I was like cursing wise
can I Cur he's like cuz I'm like a
[__] a shit's going to slip about
they were like no you're cool you can
curse whatever they literally you know
the you know the one rule over there
right yeah the noac stuff the No No
stuff and I went that would be wildly
off topic so don't worry they told us
yeah they told us that when we were
there it it's and I still brought still
made a joke about but he even said he
goes you can bring up the jeice stuff
you can say whatever you want other than
the fact stuff and I was like don't tell
me that he it was it was it was it was
[__] so funny I I had jvt on I had
Jimmy on today uh for day wve just for a
little oh cool he did your show that's
cool uh just for a little bit and
um don't do my show Jimmy that's fine he
apologized to everybody well he doesn't
want he doesn't want it look here's the
thing you said it today he mad at he
doesn't want Dom to think that that you
two guys like ganged up on him oh you
know sure no of course not and and
obviously um God Jimmy hates that guy
too which was so fun it was funny the
whole thing was just so [__] funny it
I it was so funny cuz I was standing by
on Skype
and I knew when I was about to come on
cuz I already got the boom binging and
they're like hey are you ready I'm I'm
ready and then as I'm watching the show
you see Jimmy going yeah man uh but what
about blah blah blah and then he just
kept talking he's like yeah I uh uh you
can see Jimmy going like take he was so
high he was like lose he's like ah I
don't like he was getting ready to have
me on I'm like oh I must be coming on I
did I did um I I did tell Jim I give him
a recommendation I go
since Alex seems to want to punish him
they should bring Danny Saint back to
administer the punishments to beat up
Jimmy right but but Danny likes Jimmy he
defended Jimmy before I know Danny's
gonna show up oh he's not going to see
it coming he'll turn uhhuh uh-huh he
won't see it coming has Danny Saint ever
been a baby face I mean he is in our
community definitely not definitely not
shoot like he's a baby face in our
community but our community is like aw's
audience where like the k F doesn't make
any sense like we we [__] cheer for
the heels and we boo baby faces [__]
Danny's a baby face here I can't imagine
he's a baby face outside of this
community good news is though um is I
got to show you
this
uh hold on cuz I think pessy pessy you
sent it to me or was it in Show links
the the screen the the Dom's Dom's
reply oh oh I got I got you hold on I'll
just put back in flurry it was uh oh I
sent you the Tweet yeah just the exact
tweet yeah send it yeah I'll get it I
can get it yeah s DM it directly to me
okay um so this is what um oh it's there
it's there if you just go to our Discord
it's there most recent
one where in the flurry no no no like
like I sent it to you directly on
Discord oh okay got it yeah all right um
this was great there it is
okay so his here's what's here was Dom's
reply Alex s says I have your back D luk
my dumbass producer set to debate up no
mer you do a better impression do you
want to read what he said oh I got to do
a black guy well
yeah come on oh my God oh
my Jesus chist Alex Stein's right you
are
racist h
that was very racist look you can't get
mad at a bear for getting caught in a
bear trap M just said mer just
said Mery said ugab
Booga I also did the scratch I know you
did the
scratch yeah do a do a black eye
impression yeah I'm going to stand
behind Roy and pick bugs out of his
that's
not oh my God Jesus [__]
Christ we're back
baby oh [__]
um this [__] show is my favorite
thing in the world it has never been
more fun than it's been being away from
YouTube I would say oh [__] man mhm uh
so yeah I'm not going to do the uh ugab
Booga part but uh I've never been
invited to a show and got attacked I've
I have never been invited to a show and
got he's
good you got this [__] l breaker of
the English
language read it like a breaker of
grammar holy [__] this guy sucks uh
Hooked On A bonic over here I got mad
because nobody gets the disrespect I do
I push forward alone many times I've
never seen this with anyone but me
because you don't see anything outside
of your [__] life cuz you're what
what we call narcissist that one dread
is blocking his
vision is a Dom ler [__] a first
person game where there's just a dread
constantly in the [__] screen I think
I cracked the screen no no no that's
just the D ler game okay uh it was anger
that has been built up by a year it's t
god damn it man I'm trying to read this
but I feel like I'm having a stroke
demonetized I created a website started
with oh my okay I'm I'm I'm trying I'm
[__] try bro the the punctuation is
wrong everything's wrong and starting
merch you have to like it's a question
mark and starting merch no I'm going to
do it I'm going to read it like Dennis
read Charlie's [__] political speech
okay demonetized I created a website and
starting
merch Community noted I singlehandedly
exposed the system uh not respected I
went to New York wait what does that
mean hold on wait what he's not
respected what does that mean guess what
MCH what does that mean he been to New
York
I'm not respect excuse me sir I'll have
you know I've been to New York
City your move Twitter to do what like
what is that impressive to do what the
[__] does that mean I saw cats cool how
was the
pizza what the [__]
D not the [__] I went to New York does
that
mean you broke this man's brain well no
his brain was plenty broken before I
came fair
enough uh I can't no I'm not not
respected I went to New yor
York oh my God what does that [__]
mean not conservative I earn the GOP
black votes hey Dom we don't want them
yeah we don't want you people you're see
you think like I'm like one of these
like conserva like I want you and the
[__] and the gay I want you all the
[__] out the door please thank you
um not wait not with sharing I built an
audience that will each time what no
well no no no no no no back up I'm sorry
not with sharing not with sharing I
build an audience that will I think he
meant not worth sharing like I'm not
worth sharing like his stuff well he
should have wrote that word instead of
whatever black gibberish this is instead
of well you got to understand when you
have chicken on your iPhone screen it it
sometimes you push H and it pushes F you
know why don't you just tweet out monkey
screeches at this point you [__]
illiterate [__] I build an audience
that will each time each obstacle I had
to go through in
silence what are you a Jewish mother H
love Josie Wills in the chat just said
ABA Duba daa that's pretty much what
we're dealing with here okay this is my
favorite part I was taken away because I
always considered you I was taken away
you mean taken AB back you mean you mean
what CPS when you were a kid I always
considered you a friend why I it didn't
feel good good to have that happen on a
show with someone you consider a friend
you said friend too much hey friendo let
me tell you something nobody's friends
in this business Show Business not show
friends that's what I that's a little
phrase I learned put that on a shirt put
that on a shirt put that on a shirt and
then the last part and by the way the
last part the part that just Jesus
[__] Christ I reviewed the video and
I believe you Alex thank
you God damn you really are [__]
stupid
have you seen have you seen the
people that have been screaming at Alex
to fire Jimmy screaming at him have you
seen I have been let me see I I had one
here very hold on let me see it's
uh okay look here you go this the check
this one out this [__]
has 103,000 followers okay wow you're
not only a terrible producer but you're
also a POS for stupid e call calling in
that other [__] for backup that's you
you're the other [__] in this
situation you both continually cut Dom
off when he tried to defend himself
seriously go [__] yourself I like Alex
and feel bad for him that was all your
fault you're you're a [__] man uh
you're a [__] who looks like Andy wy's
e-girlfriend um also um wasn't either
one getting cut off the whole time you
were getting cut off the entire
time I got cut off the entire entire
time I was nothing but a
gentleman they're calling you merch
colon the other
[__] well don't use colon and [__]
in the same
sentence well they they use the colon
symbol oh wow we're already getting some
more new ones here guys this is really
crazy are we making waves yeah we're
making hey Dom I'm Making Waves here
look did you know that uh on this day in
black history D Luke was the first
African-American to steal and remake a
100 memes
oh no what's happening did you know that
it begins uh D I believe this is what uh
white folks refer to as the other shoe
dropping or Jordan in your Cas I was
going to say lugs but okay Jordan works
it's gonna say l or Tims cuz he's been
to New York I'll have you know I'm not
respect a worldly man he that's like the
I drive a Dodge Stratus it really is
just not respected I'm been to New York
anyone with like $12 for the subway can
get
there oh [__] I've been to New York it's
been my favorite my favorite thing what
the [__] did that mean 's been in New
York okay is that tweet still up yeah
like did you read that straight wow he
really is a [__] that is that is up he
has not taking cuz that's a tweet I'd be
embarrassed of the next day like bro the
hod Twins were like you should do a show
and I'm like have you heard him talk
well have you heard the H twin mean
what did you say they sound like freed
slaves escape slaves escape slaves which
is how we got barricade garage on the
show literally cuz he just saw a clip of
me calling them escaped SL and he's like
that shit's
[Laughter]
hilarious and you grow up in New York I
have to respect you a lot yeah dude I am
the most respected on this show respect
I spent the most amount of time there
you're basically
Spider-Man speak okay but I want to be
Miles Morales oh why you want the food
stamps by the way what is this Miles
Morales a controversy Peter Parker
always sucked you know Peter Parker was
a little lame let a SPI have it like you
Peter Parker's a nerd big yeah [__]
Peter Parker sucks also Peter Parker
still exists it's not like they killed
him but they they act like they replaced
Wolverine with a black guy like we all
love Wolverine he's beloved you know
what I mean made more sense if Wolverine
was a black gu uh excuse me it would be
pit balverine thank you but he would he
would always CU you know he smoked
cigars so he wouldd always have one like
stuck in head mask sticking out who's my
dad
Pub piece of [__] he could smoke
Newports because of the healing
factor I don't have any money loaded on
my food card Pub are his bones copper
wire metal detect to goes off but it's
not his claws it's still the gun he has
in his
[Laughter]
waistband